well hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I am John Humphrey we're gonna
watch from one of the greatest YouTube
channels that ever existed arts peer
entertainment their tune sandwich
segment you know from how it should have
ended honest trailers and cinemasins I
really feel like these guys are right up
there with the best of them all
spider-man far from home trailer spoof
before we go into that a couple of
things we're gonna film our spider-man
far from home non-spoiler review that
should be up tomorrow morning spoiler
review should be up on 4th of July or
July 5th and secondly I was on screen
junkies news fandom Entertainment go
check out that segment it was wonderful
we talked about iconic directors for
quite a bit Dan Merle Maggie Mae fish
and Emma five food is a wonderful time
please go check that out and yeah anywho
let's hop on to this video John yeah you
ready I'm so wrapped so exists is how
we're gonna get a refresher before we
film our review Thank You spider-man
[Music]
thank you I have a detailed inventory of
all your garments and undergarments just
part of my job what did you say your
name is creepy
yeah creepy is my brother but he's also
big fan years money
[Music]
I see his face I love those Dukes new
dress
what do you like Ivan inventory up all
my dresses do you get how creepy that
sounds but is that a new shirt because I
don't recognize it from my Peter Parker
evening right database just about my
shirt spider-man
we met at mr. Starks funeral is my
friend gonna be okay oh sure he just not
back oh my god if I wanted to kill you
there's gotta be someone else you can
use infiltrating a no franchise Captain
Marvel over in two seconds
oh pretty strange dude Oh black panther
no okay Superman runs the local
authorities and first response teams you
know the people who actually get paid to
do this stuff
this studio second database is here I
create I mean I fight giant well at
least we know what's coming next part
what and when their powers could buy
this is an actual planet kid the next
one's gonna be wind and it's gonna take
the both of us to break it no problem I
can break wind in my sleep boy
that's crazy what why would you even
think that when you sound exactly like
him whatever city you're visiting he
also happens to be in town your aunt
organizes its charity work last
Halloween costume was a little too
convincing especially when you worked up
that Prowler but today I'd say it's
mainly in the pants we just walk okay
it's what it's a thing guys do sometimes
you'll see this time you see spider-man
he'll be wearing my pants I told you
yeah wonder where my friend Peter Parker
is right now
[Music]
oh no I'm fighting a massive golden
monster oh I see you are chief of
injustice and now you only do don't
worry man Mysterio puts people first
oh man that Mysterio is so mysterious no
I literally have no idea who he is and
I'm so sexy
who is that guy it's like Doctor Strange
got his head stuck in a fishbowl he's no
spider-man what is it with humans -
people let's just get a suit I told you
we swapped pants oh great how am I gonna
explain this to them when they wake up
what do you mean wake up hey check it
out I told you of course not but this
person I've never met before is right
please subscribe and have already Rita
and Jose really appreciate it they may
be far from your home I've known Peter
Benjamin Parker they are so lucky that
every single person of my grade got
dusted for five years just like I did
resulting in maximum continuity I kept
him down well I guess that explains why
it's two feet taller has a full beard -
three kids well done guys round of
applause right into the mic don't lower
it John don't
now elastic blasted
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's funny I thought that Nick Fury
sounded a little bit like I got the Sam
Jackson but like I think something about
the pitch of his voice or whatever also
sounded like Chris Rock to me so I made
me think of an alternate world where
Chris Rock plays Nick Fury instead races
I am I'm trying to be oh because what
I'm trying to get to is that is the fact
that I can't tell those guys apart man
well sane I'm glad you're being on have
you ever seen them both in the same room
together they have to be the same guy no
no you're a racist oh man I forgot how
it works
no don't really hardly be racist when I
love black people to set like a
benevolent reverse racism
I especially favor one where I heard
that if you pivot your videos to the
alt-right group there oh yeah I'm really
proud now I accuse you all right that's
more a generates this check I mean the
overlap of that Venn diagram is probably
something of note but you know I guess
anything can happen and I'm sure that
there's some old writers who somehow are
traces no yeah absolutely Buddhists are
only about super right-wing there have
not gone on topic at all this is all
because Nam made a racist comment about
a white guy doing a Sam Jackson voice
John let's get back to you
basics this is what I love most about
Mattoon sandwich does our their silly
puns
PPP the park we're here to pick up a
passport a package a parcel in the
pickup pickup peppers for pepper pause
please I like when they break in the
scenes you know like with the toast
totally stark jokes like that it just
seems like so dumb like so funny you
know an incidental thing that Peter
would maybe be going through between big
fights are between little moments at
school just oh they seem to have a
pretty deep understanding the characters
and without spoiling anything about far
from home I felt like amy was
the character here and then she was in
the movie I agree why I thought of that
heavily and I loved that they changed
Happy's giant check to just a gigantic
backstage pass it's true I thought their
Mysterio was really good though too
especially with the way he's laying in
the little I'm great at creating I mean
fighting monsters and stuff like that
and like that's a joke that can be kind
of rote but the combination of that and
the impression of Jake Gyllenhaal you
know Jake Gyllenhaal doesn't have one of
those voices that I'm like oh let me
just whip out an impression so when I
hear one that's close I'm like oh wow
well done yes you know I'm not gonna say
what they got right and what they didn't
get wrong in terms of their predictions
there are some things though that I
liked that far from home actually
acknowledges that they make fun of here
yeah yeah you addressed it in the movie
but it's like I wonder how this would
have played to us if we hadn't seen the
movie already you know they were still
wondering some of those things yeah
exactly how it would turn out I mean
even right down to the core of like this
little bit where he's being torn apart
by fire then you have this this woman in
the streets screaming at him this East
Coast personality yelling at him while
he's in Europe well I mean that's the
essence of spider-man right there's like
he's trying to fight this big old crazy
guy but then you know it's the little
people on the ground who are yeah
unappreciative but that dilemma though
of an Avenger and John try make a
serious point the alt-right people not
all of them are racist that's what this
videos videos we wanted to it address a
serious issue out there anyway to be
able to execute this properly arts for
entertainment you guys are wildly
consistent with your animation I think
your your comedy bits or even getting
tighter I feel like there was a point
where they were getting a little
self-indulgent there's always they've
always been hilarious but this something
like this seems to be one other tight is
constructive ones like from watching
Captain Marvel the latest in Game one
and in this one then knocking it out of
the park each and every time and so
please guys go check out their patreon
page go subscribe to their YouTube
channel I would like to give a patron
the day shout out before
we wrap this video up to a man named
Brandon him it's like I am apparently is
Larry David you know Easy's undercover
that's why that's why he's got a
pseudonym I was looking through our
patreon and he actually just pledged
today for our shout out reward here and
I haven't replied to him yet he said hey
guys I just wanted to say that you're
one of my favorite YouTube channels and
I absolutely love watching all your
videos as so many times just binge
watching your videos up till like 3:00
a.m. knowing I should get up early but I
can't stop watching because you're so
entertaining and funny to watch it's
cool is he's part of the alright tuna
great job with it
Oh for all the new content coming out
keep it up guys
love Brandon well in terms of new
content this videos a great example of
what we thanks so much man honestly I
hate knowing that I am disrupting your
sleep schedule yeah sleep is very
important John and I consistently get to
saw the nine hours every day yeah that's
such a sterling sleep schedule you know
it's it's great and I think that you
would benefit wonderfully from it
welcome to our patreon page
I love the latest season that you did if
you ever want to come over here and
sleep you know you just let us know
you're more than welcome to I don't know
where you're from but if you're not from
California fly to California crash on
the kitchen floor
because I don't want leader people just
sleeping on my couch do maybe we can
make that a reward tier though for like
a certain amount of money you could just
Airbnb it 5 bucks more than the shoutout
yeah it's very sweet I know what it's
like to binge watch videos from other
youtubers and be up till 3:00 a.m. you
know people like Ben Shapiro people like
steven crowder or my favorites they
share my point of view yes and I know
you share our similar parts you know I
hope
still pledged you pledged for 12 hours
it's already returned it has for a
refund immediately hey you know you
gotta get those subversive ideas don't
don't be a sheeple you know red pill and
y'all we're ending this can I get some
sleep he's